procore is a b2b sas software company
that connects um all of the companies
that have to work together
uh to put a project
to build a building right from where you
are
standing right now to
infrastructure roads airports etc
digitize all those processes that used
to be in paper
bring them digital and now we are in the
cusp of being able to leverage that data
to bring
um more roi for our customers
about the construction industry is a 10
trillion dollar industry is one of the
largest in the world
um and it has just started to be
digitized in the past 10 years in fact
and what that means is that you know
you've seen construction sites with
these big papers with their drawings
binders where they have the checklist of
things that are going wrong in the
building
all of those processes still today in
some part most parts of the world are
running on paper
for huge huge projects
there's very little data on how they
build these projects because everything
just happens offline
but that is starting to change a hundred
and ten ten terabytes of data and
growing are running through procore um
and that number keeps growing as we
expand globally so it is now that it is
very interesting to start looking at
that data and figuring out what can we
do and that's the question
that we have at procore we're starting
to try to figure out where can we bring
the most value with our data
and so what i'm going to talk to you
about today is how to get roi of these
products as a product manager right what
do you need to look at to build data
products and to convince your
organization such as procore
that you need to invest in data and how
do you then manage that investment to
make sure that you're not losing trust
from your stakeholders
and that you can continue get funding to
be able to build your products
and when i say data products i do mean
products that are using models in
between the product the process and
customers why because
industries like construction that are
not very modern and forward in their
digitization look at data products as a
dashboard right it's a one-to-one
relationship where there is a customer
and then there's the product and when i
bring more data to the system the
product improves marginally for my own
use case but it doesn't improve it for
the rest of the users in the platform
well when you have a data product with a
model in between
the model improves every time new users
are starting to add data to that model
and so this data products benefit of
network effects to build um and to build
sustainable over time
so what we focus on when we build data
products is in establishing data
learning loops meaning the job of the
product manager as we see it in in
broker but this is my point of view is
that our job is to find those data
learning loops for our models so that
they're self-sustaining and that they
can keep growing and bringing benefit to
the entire network
and what do i mean why it's so hard to
build data products at organizations i
used to work for a company called figure
eight
we were in the conference and the talk
before i was talking about data labeling
figure it is a platform for machine
learn
labeling data basically in one side you
have customers that are trying to get
data labeling to create their ground
truth and on the other side you have
data labelers that are getting paid
to label this data
but the interesting thing about my job
at figure 8 was looking at all the
verticals and the diff the variety of
customers that are trying to build data
products and unfortunately eighty
percent of these customers um are
failing in their machine learning
projects uh there's a lot of churn that
figure eight had because products
projects start with a lot of investment
and then they burn and then they don't
start again because product managers are
losing interest from their stakeholders
so i've been become very interested in
figuring out how do we create a process
in which we can start data products our
organizations that are not
data native that are starting to figure
out what do they do with their data and
the reason why it's so hard is because
you start with hype right otherwise you
wouldn't be able to get started
but your first project is never going to
be the most successful
is going to flop is going to have errors
and as soon as that happened your
stakeholders your leadership is going to
be
dissolutioned is going to feel that what
it is promised is not what they were
expecting and so it is it is there's a
lot of values there right and then you
convince them then you make you may find
a little bit of success in that product
but just when you find success is when
you need to start telling them that they
need to invest more because maybe you
need to
get infrastructure you need to build a
data platform they need to pour more
monies because you need to label more
data well the product that you told them
that you were building is just starting
to have success
and you still are asking for more money
to build more product and so then you go
and again you have to build more trust
and that's the whole ups and downs of
what is to build data products or
organizations that are not starting from
the ground up building these products
and that are not used to building it
and the reason why building these data
learning loops is so important is
because as soon as you can find that
human in the loop that idea that your
own customers are create are improving
your model over time
then the investment that you're making
is less and less and you can sustain
those projects over time
so
from my perspective what you need to get
right are three things and i'm gonna go
through these three things of what we've
done at procore to make sure that we can
sustain our investment in data and data
products and ai
the first one is that before you get
started this is not only a thing about
ai this is not anything about your
machine learning model is that you need
to have a very clear mission and vision
and a product strategy with a clear path
to enabling these data loops right so
forget about your ideas for machine
learning for ai if your company doesn't
have a clear strategy on how they're
going to win in the market and what your
stakeholders
care about
then go and do that first and don't
invest in data before you can do that
because data is an enabler of this
strategy
the second thing is that you're going to
find a north star with a goldilocks
starting starting point and i'll explain
what i mean by that
and the third thing for product managers
in my team what i tell them is our job
60 to 70 percent of the time is
stakeholder management which that means
is storytelling
and the error that we can constantly do
is that we explain this machine learning
projects in the in the language of the
technical audience right we talk about
accuracy we talk about f1
we talk about how our model is improving
and we convince stakeholders that that's
what they need to care about
but in reality what they need to care
about is what they care about forever
which is customer outcomes and that's
the language that you need to be using
so let's go on the first one like what
does it mean to build a strategy that
you can use to build machine data
products
well
in the case of procore you need to have
or in any case you need to have a very
clear mission and tactics to win that
mission
right so in the case of procore our
mission is to connect everyone in
construction on a global platform we
have these on banners we have this on
everything we read everybody knows that
a mission as an organization is to
connect everyone in construction on a
global platform and so if everybody's
aligned around that then you can use
that just that paragraph to figure out
what do you do to connect everyone in
construction on a global platform
so
the strategy also has to have tactics
right what are the concrete things that
the organization is going to do
to win in that mission
so three things that we think are
important for procore are connecting all
stakeholders meaning and stakeholders in
a construction project means the owner
that person that is going to put money
to build the building uh the general
contractor which is the group of the
company that is managing and building
the pro and managing the project and
then the specialty contractors all the
trades that need to come together the
electrician the concrete all of those
are sub companies that come together in
essence is a network that needs to work
together in one platform
so we need to figure out how do we do
that and how do we do it really well the
second one is that we need to accelerate
growth in our financial products
well for us it's very important to have
in our strategy
a project that basically we need to grow
because financially as a as a company we
need to grow somewhere so the company
decides that that's where we're going to
put a lot of a lot of our investments in
growing our financials portfolio
and the third one is that we need to win
pre-construction pre-construction is
before you build ground
there's a lot to happen from the
architects designing the building all
the way from the general contractors and
the specialty contractors finding each
other to be able to work together so how
do we win in pre-construction so that
our our competitors don't take that side
of the market as well
and why that is important you figure
like you may be asking
this is about data why is that important
well because you can use those tactics
to then figure out what are your north
star questions you can translate each of
the tactics that the organization cares
about in questions that you can answer
with data so in the case of connecting
all stakeholders a question that we
think is important because obviously
we've done the research we understand
with our customers we present we put
this in front of our customers and say
these are our tactics what are the main
things that you're concerned about in
these areas so in the first one is what
are the best companies i can hire for
this project that's what they care about
when they want to connect with each
other right just like any other
network they want to find the best
people that they can connect with
data can solve that the second one is a
salary growth in financial products well
our customers buy our financial
portfolio because they want to make
profit and what they want to know is
what do they need to do in our product
to be able to mitigate risk and
create profit
potentially something that we can solve
with data and the third one in
pre-construction is do i have a
competitive bid meaning i'm a specialty
contractor there's a new building
that is going to be built in an area of
my
community and i want to bid on that
project our specialty contractors want
to know is that the right project for me
and do i have a winning bid and so we
could help them with data on that so we
decided that those are our three
as they relate to these three tactics
those are three questions that we were
going to go and answer
and so why are these important for your
team these are goal posts this is how
you define success for your machine
learning team for your for your data
product team
there are three things that this goal
posts enable you to do
the first one is that they will help you
understand how customers attempt to
answer these questions today
right so even without technology our
customers are figuring out how do they
make profit
even without technology our customers
are connecting with each other and they
may look they may be looking at
different data sets at different inputs
to find that answer
finding those inputs is what ultimately
will convert into our ground truth is
the data that we need to be able to
train our models
the second one is that we identify the
data needed to answer these questions
right where are we going to find that
data do we find it from sensors do we
already have it in our database do we
need to go and acquire that data it
creates a strategy for data acquisition
and it helps define the scope of these
questions that we're trying to answer
and the third one is that with these
questions as a team you start defining
what are the process to acquire uh
prepare
um and um and process this data right
your data engineering team can start
figuring out if your data to answer
question a is of streaming well well i
may need to build a streaming platform
so that i can acquire that data from
streaming
if it's about connecting different data
sources maybe you have something s3 and
the other one is and you have for
example us we may have unstructured data
in an s3 bucket and maybe we have a
structured data another database your
team can start figuring out eventually
we need to start connecting these
systems to bring that data together so
your data platform team starts forming
without having to invest too much money
yet in a data platform i want to be very
careful with that that
some
you may want to just immediately go and
invest in a data platform but that's not
what is important here what is important
is just defining what are the parameters
that you may need to invest in the
future
all right so that was the first part
of a mission with tactics and
north star questions that help the team
define
how do customers answer the question
today so that you can identify what data
you need the second one is where do you
get that data and the third one is the
processes that you may need to process
that data and it's all around those
north star questions you're not going to
diverge in finding other problems
but then you're not going to go and
solve those questions because those are
really really hard questions to solve
and this is where the majority of the
team the the companies that i saw at
figure eight make them make the first
mistake
they basically burn their shots
they choose a project that is either
that is too small that nobody cares
about
or is way way too big and too hot that
everybody cares about and they fail
then they ultimately lose funding so you
need to choose something that is
somewhere in the middle not too hot not
too cold why because if you choose that
project that is just right it allows you
to define what are the milestones that
it will take you to finally answer that
question that you're trying to answer it
also allows you to make the mistakes
that you need to make without breaking a
very important workflow for the
organization and it allows your team to
experiment to figure out different
models to fit to have the time to
understand how to build what you need to
build
so finding the right project is key so
how do you do that what are the things
that you need to consider
what is a goldilocks project
what a goldilocks project has is that it
has a real customer problem tied to one
of your north star questions right it
has to be
real customer problem that is around the
questions that you're trying to answer
that's the first and foremost
the second one is that the data needs to
be readily available
if you don't have a way to get data from
sensors just don't answer that question
at the beginning if you don't have a way
to stream data to your systems don't do
that to get started right what's data
that is readily available that you don't
have to bring from multiple sources and
that you can immediately access with the
resources that you have
the third is that has to be measurable
from the onset right many teams made the
mistake to say
i'll measure it later once i get more
users onto the product
and that is the mistake that is a
mistake you have to be able to know what
is the outcome that i'm trying to
achieve and what are the metrics to
achieve that outcome and it needs to be
instrumented from the beginning and data
needs to start flowing into that metric
right away
the fourth one is that it should test
your end-to-end development cycle this
is why it cannot be too small because if
it's too small of a project then you
don't understand what does it mean to
deploy it in the application you don't
know you don't create a challenge for at
least getting out of your database and
into your into the system right so you
need to figure out what is the right
size that it you can fully complete the
cycle of data development all the way
not just to deployment but to building
that learning loop that we discussed
right your customers need to be able to
give you feedback and the feedback that
they give whether it's thumbs up on top
down or any other tactic needs to go
back into your systems to feed the model
and improve it because you need to prove
that your model is going to be better
over time with that first goldilocks
and then the fifth one which i think is
also incredibly important is that it
cannot be in a critical workflow so if
your company's promise is to
um
make payments easier well don't build
something that will make payments harder
right don't choose a project that is
immediately rel immediately attached to
the value of your of your company to
your customers
pick something that is adjacent to that
workflow so that you don't break
something and you'll be surprised i
think when i listed these things
it seems that to me like everybody would
be like well that's obvious
but these mistakes happen all the time
we are very ambitious we want to pick
something that is important and we
choose things that ultimately are going
to slow down our
progress all right so how did we choose
our first goldilocks project the first
thing that we did in the organization
the north star for us one of the north
stars that we chose was
what do we need to do to ensure the
highest profit in this project this is
something that our customers ask all the
time they buy our financial products for
a lot of money but ultimately they want
to find that answer and they pay a lot
of people just to manage budgets to
figure out how to make them make profit
but that's a very hard question to
answer because there's so many things
that happen in a building over years
that is very hard to answer that
question right away
so there are multiple questions that are
sub questions to that main question that
the budget managers at construction
companies follow right one of them is
for example is my contingency budget
right for this project so contingency is
do i have extra what is my extra budget
if something goes wrong and do i budget
enough that's a question that
is easier to solve than if the entire
project is going to be profitable
a second question that we could go and
solve is are we at risk of general
conditions funds overspend general
conditions is the money that our
customers spend on their own people so
this can be controlled by them it's not
it's not the materials it's not the
structure it's their employees right so
how much money are they budgeting for
staff
uh and the third one is what type of
projects are more profitable for us
right even before they start the project
they want to make sure that they're
attacked that they're entering into a
project that they can uh be successful
at so now these questions become more
attainable any of these questions could
be a goldilocks project but if we go one
by one
in the five steps that i mentioned some
of these questions we may have not had
the data we needed they may not be
measurable immediately they may be a
critical workflow for our customers so
the one that we picked after we went
through the five steps
was are we at risk of general conditions
funds overspend
and so we built we built a prototype and
we went through the entire development
cycle i'm not going to go through that
but the point here is that what we were
trying to do is build something that was
important to our customers that we can
help them right away that will challenge
our team end to end and that we can
measure and what do we mean by measure
right one of the mistakes that we make
in
these data projects is that our metric
for our data products are accuracy
or something related to that technology
and that's something that you need to
avoid at all cost you may have that
metric for your team internally to know
if the model is good so that it solves a
problem but ultimately what is a metric
that the organization cares about in our
case we we care about usage of our
financial products we care about
engagement of our financial portfolio so
something we could move for the
organization as we solve the problem for
our customers is engagement with our
financial tools
and so the metric that we put here is
that we were going to get 90
of customers or users that see that
that chart that we show of general
overspend to take an action directly on
the budget tool as a result of seeing
that insight and we could measure with
and we can measure with the funnel if
customers were seeing the insight
clicking on the
take action and then ultimately making a
change in the budget tool and we defined
success for the organization as that
right we didn't go and tell them
something that it was different from
what they needed to expect from us so we
set expectations at the right level so
that we can be successful in what we're
trying to achieve
and then we also define a learning loop
right so we created a feedback mechanism
in which our customers were going to
give us feedback on the general
conditions and then we will take that
feedback from our customers and then
improve
the model over time so the entire
project it took us
three quarters to build uh and
we were able to start driving roi of
that product and start building other
projects that were a little bit more
ambitious
but
the next thing that you need to do which
is very important is as you go in that
journey because that's not going to be
the main project that you're going to do
is that you need to start managing your
stakeholders there's a lot of people in
the organization that really care about
data especially when you're investing so
much money that the organization has
most of your funds in your p in your r d
team are ultimately going to go to your
data team and so a lot of the
expectations that the leadership has
will be what is the roi that you're
bringing and is the job of this team to
manage those expectations
and some of the questions that you're
going to get in organizations that are
not used to working with data are things
like
should we solve a different problem this
problem is not important or this problem
is too hard or this problem is not
important
we're not seeing the success you
promised this is probably because you
promised something that you could not
achieve
this is very expensive where are the
results right we just signed a new
vendor that is promising to get us the
data faster and organizing it faster and
where is the roi of that that you're
demonstrating right should we sell your
data this is a very common one right
once you get the solution with your data
products the main thing that your
leadership is going to say is we have a
lot of data why don't we package and
sell it like what is your monetization
strategy with data this is usually
because you're just building the wrong
thing etc etc so the goal here is
how do i make sure that i
i take all of these opinions and
continuously drive alignment across the
organization
and the reason i'm talking about this is
because it's surprising when i joined
procore how much work the entire team
needs to spend on just aligning the
organization on the road because the
road is very long and it's going to take
a multi-year span
to try to find the roi that the
organization cares about
so how do you do this
there are three things that i um
we do all the time
but at the end of the day is that you
need to start whittling out all the
distractions
the first thing is that new
opportunities will emerge all the time
there's all the time a new thing that we
can do so keep your organization focused
and your team focus on the north stars
of the strategy right your slides always
have to show this is our mission
these are our north stars and these are
the questions that we're after if we
achieve these questions we're going to
get to our strategy and where the
organization needs to go so repeat and
repeat that question in that story
the second one is that you're going to
have to communicate very often and
you're going to use that goldilocks
project the success of that goldilocks
project to demonstrate the end-to-end
process what metrics you're working with
and by the way a lot of the time
some of the things some of the
stakeholders that you need to manage is
your own team right the team gets tired
of not seeing progress the team gets
confused of where we're going and so
he's usually in every stand up in every
meeting that you have maybe every
quarter you're trying to figure out and
trying to remind them where is it that
you're going to go
and then the third one is keep your team
motivated with the why and bring
customer stories we bring customer
stories to our meeting all the time and
try to show them what we can do with
data and the problems that we're solving
so i'm going to stop there because
that's basically the gist of the of of
the
presentation about how to get roi from
your data products
[Applause]